and welcome to this southeastern area
planning committee meeting on wednesday
the 6th of april 2022
my name is councillor vanessa bell and i
am the chairman of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consents are being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite invite you at the
appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can i ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn your microphones on
and then turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that in the event of a fire
please use the fire exits marked with
the green running man
item two apologies for absence i believe
we have no apologies this evening berna
is that right
that's great
thank you
item three minutes it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 9th of march
2022 found on pages 7 to eight are
approved as a true and accurate record
councillor duik and then council
champion madame chairman um
relative to those minutes of the last
meeting i did raise the point at the
last meeting about red lion's farm
three four months since we previously
discussed it it still isn't back on this
paper tonight is anybody actually doing
anything about it i'm afraid i'm going
to put you on the spot councillor
johnson asked if you can counsellor i've
got
reef i've changed your role mr johnson
i'm afraid i'm putting you on the spot
can you help us out with that
uh
thank you chair um my understanding from
colleagues is that um the matter will be
reported at the next committee in fall
unfortunately i wasn't privy to
the sort of background discussions on
that although i am familiar with red
lions itself
uh but how it relates to the matter that
came out of the committee that
considered the application and to which
it was deferred
um i haven't been privy to that but at
the next committee i am assured that
that will be the case and i will be
supporting that with additional
information
thank you mr johnson councillor duke
again then chancellor thank you madam
chairman if i may come back on that i
mean by the next meeting i believe if
i've done my sums right it'll be five
months since we deferred it it really is
not good enough somebody could have
dealt with it very very easily very very
quickly
four and a half months ago we could have
three and a half months ago we could
have had it here tonight
it's not good enough somebody somewhere
is not doing the jobs properly thank you
chairman thank you councillor channel
i hadn't missed um because it's quite
clear
and it was recorded it was briefly an
update on this application circulated to
all members yeah
no nothing no no i think
well i've not been advised of anything
members so
certainly not holding anything from you
counsellor flicker thank you very much
um
i'm surprised it's not actually in the
minutes to be honest with you
um and i know it was in the minutes last
time so i'm surprisingly nobody from the
planning department um
actually picked up on this but
while we've got the attention mr johnson
who understands now and um i've taken
uh oh i won't say overall but he's
certainly taken more active in interest
in enforcement i mean would you prepare
to be with the
councillors from this committee to
discuss the southeast area planning
enforcement cases this is something that
happened before your time but i think
this would be very very useful
particularly for this committee because
historically we've always had more
enforcement cases within this area than
anywhere else so maybe you'd like to
meet with the chairman afterwards not
after this meeting but sometime and
perhaps work towards that because i
think that's something that the members
have
certainly got a lot of out of in the
past
it was something which i which i
actually brought forward seven years ago
and we managed to compact this quite a
lot so i think it's useful for everybody
and i'm sorry to go from that tangent
i think we can
look at having that on the agenda for
the next meeting mr johnson
oh hello
yes
please do
all members that there was a resolution
at the council
that um enforcement will not be dealt
with on area planning committees but
will be dealt with directly by canadian
so any members that have an issue
they contact
and i would like to get the minutes
agree pretty quickly if we can please
members
yeah if councillor shannon can speak and
then we can agree the minutes that would
be lovely
at full members
i made the point
when you're actually posting this
one
actually
but at one time and my body hasn't been
overtaken it was agreed that the
planning committees could meet follow
the chairman calling such a meeting
to look at the enforcement only would be
an informal meeting not in public and
the enforcement officers will be there
no individual member can instruct an
officer on enforcement and indeed a
committee can't instruct and say to mr
johnson go and put the stock market on
this but what can happen is members
could go through in the worksheet of
them ask questions and there could be
local knowledge and that resulted
actually in some other cases being
cloned
or perhaps progressed in the light of
some information that came forward and
it was really the fact
solely for enforcement that informed
meeting held by um at the discretion of
the committee chairman to call it and
that is what i said
i considered all committee chairs you
have to consider calling a meeting to my
knowledge that has not been removed from
the system
and i don't know that that resolve women
takes it but if it does i'm not sure all
members would have realized that was the
case i see it more in case we can't say
mr johnson
but what we can do is go through a list
and look at stuff and ask questions and
that can lead to some cases actually be
closed or progression in action
so can we have confirmation of that
please bernard at some
whether that is still active
yes
[Music]
of course enforcement
okay
thank you thank you very much councillor
jewett my channel yes madam chairman
jessica
council mr channel said there was in
fact one such meeting held the southeast
um
it was a long long time ago
and i don't believe there's been any
other meetings held since thank you shim
okay thank you but i don't think we have
another meeting before thee do we have
another meeting before the statutory
annual i'm not sure so i think we i
i suggest i'm one in between now and the
statutory annual because we don't know
he'll be sharing this committee
afterwards so i think i shall leave that
until after the statutory annual now
moving on can we please agree these
minutes by sentence
thank you
item four declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regards paragraph
6-8 inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
do we have any councillor stamp helm and
fluker we'll start with you
yeah thank you madam chair just that i'm
a member of essex county council who has
statute to consult teas on all planning
well not all planning applications and
some of them but i can't see anything
that puts me in a difficult position um
i would like to say though that i have
had correspondence with um some of the
um
items or some of the applicants on this
but it's non-pecuniary not done anything
wrong so okay thanks thank you council
hell i believe you were next thank you
madam chairman item six
mrs um
mrs patton is also a member of this
council and known to me and everybody
else i think we're all in the same
position with that councillor helm
councillor fluka was that what you were
intending i still declare that because
i'm acquainted to the patents um you
know they're not friends but i'm
acquainted to them yeah thank you
and members just to remind you that
should any uh
such interests become
um
yet become
apparent thank you i've
lost the ability to speak
apparent throughout meeting members
should declare those so let's move on
then to item five
zero one one six zero var which is a
variation of approval woodpeckers 15 man
gap chase and you'll find this on pages
9 to 28 of your agenda
there is no members update for this
application so i'm going to move
straight to mr johnson and the
technology to present this report
i suppose just as a preamble i'm uh
in the
whether enviable or unenviable position
of presenting all the cases today
so i'll be doing my usual position and
also
juggling with the uh with the
presentation as well um
so
woodpeckers 15 man gap chase burnham on
couch
this application proposes the variation
on condition 2 on approved planning
permission
2001 2884
which is the demolition of the existing
outbuildings an erection of five
number
dwellings
um i would just sort of add that
with this proposal there would be six
dwellings on site which includes the
existing dwelling which sort of lies
central and i'll point that out
in the drawings when we look at that
the recommendation is to prove subject
to the applicant entering into a legal
agreement pursuant to section 106
of the town and country planning act and
also subject to condition set out at
section eight
so just go through the drawings we can
um
this is a site
highlight it here
uh and this is the location plan this
has the the outline of
the
scheme
that the 20
uh the 2020 scheme
with this particular layout
the block plans here show
well under existing which is the layout
proposed under the existing extant
planning permission
i'll just point out a few things
largely the same
major
visual changes
from the plan would be in this area here
this is plot three
uh this is the existing house which i
mentioned
uh we've got plot one two three four and
five just for identification sake
um
dot five is a range uh parallel to the
boundary here so that's the side
elevation there
plot four this is its rear elevation so
again we can see the simulation with the
boundary
on plot three um which is a significant
part of these amendments
um
the the side elevation of plot three is
uh parallel with with the boundary here
and the rear elevation
is up here so i'll just sort of point
those things out
and this is the proposed scheme so we
can see the changes here
um
three
um
sort of
turned
uh sort of 45 degrees with its rear
elevation now facing the boundary here
um these are rear extensions just to
point that out there
the other
arrangements are you know again you know
as as approved you can see garages here
existing house
and so on garage go over there
no change to anywhere else on the site
so we've got plots one and two
elevations approved under the previous
extent mission so plots one and two here
facing the street
so that's the front
these are the sides
there's rear
uh plot three
the bungalow
as approved and the extent planning
permission there we can see that there
front rear and
sides
and
this is plus one two and three but
effectively plot three is a similar
design to plots one and two
you see the rear rear extension there i
pointed that out earlier
elevation has plot four
and the changes to the other buildings
are set out in the report are
normal windows
uh roof lights etc
those elevations there just
you see the front elevation
yeah dormer there
rare elevation
no changes there exactly the same
side elevations
there's a
flight in the
in the
in the hip roof there
you just see the changes here on this
elevation
and disapprove
you can see that there's been windows
removed from there
and elevation five is approved
again just point out the changes
in the front elevation a couple of
dormers
and in the rear elevation
we can see some
changes again in the in the apex here
we've got some
windows inserted
uh this is serving the
um
the space created within the roof
um these particular windows here
and then we can see
more roof lights
side elevation
no change
there
and we can see the floor plans these
were approved
the fundamental things really is um
under plot three
obviously that then now has a has a
first floor
and here is in the roof
um these are identified as games rooms
storage um
and again obviously just to point out
you know these are roofs
uh with hips so they've got restricted
height
um and
they're
we can see where the roof lights are
here
serving the
landing and the and the stairwell there
this over here is identified as storage
we've got a roof light over there
and we've got plot floor spot for
approved and proposed
um
sorry the uh
i can move this sorry burner
um
but again just point out some
in the storage area we've got some roof
lights there serving and landing
any other changes identified on the
elevations
and
again plot five is the areas up in the
roof
as existing roof space
and again a couple of roof lights here
and as i mentioned in the apex we have
these windows in the in the rear
elevations at that level
this is a
garage that was approved what it's been
changed to
got some photographs
of the site
i see access here
look at north
south view
photographs dwellings opposite
application site
and
then just more photos looking at the
site itself
obviously development is is underway um
we can see
site preparation etc
right so i'll
just take this back to the
the block plan showing the existing and
and and the proposed
i'll just make up a few comments
um as i said three point one point four
sets out the changes
most significant is the alteration of
the bungalow plot three to a two-story
dwelling with rooms in the roof
the impact of plot 3 on surrounding
residential immunity is set at 5.5 of
the report
as well as any other impacts
it is noted the location of the other
dwellings have not changed in terms of
their relationship to surrounding
properties and the boundaries
plot 3 is set approximately 14 meters
from the single story element to its
rear
from the rear boundary and a distance of
almost 20 meters
from the rear boundary to the two-story
element that's the that's the new
proposed element
uh to this would be added the distance
of the existing house
to its rear so
again as quite evident here and what was
explained there it's the distance of the
boundary here
and then in addition that's real
boundaries and additions is the distance
there
um this existing property obviously had
the transverse relationship to the
boundary so it's set obliquely
in terms of any direct
views so just bring that to members
attention
um
so
and subsequent paragraphs on the section
five also sets out the nature of the
impact and consider these to be
acceptable and these are within the
impact on terms of residential immunity
um the other changes that we've pointed
out normal windows and roof lights in
the other in the other properties
uh 5.8.2 the report sets out the context
of the affordable housing requirement
now required as a result of the changes
and the weight to be placed on that
particularly balance in the loss of a
two-bedroom dwelling and its replacement
with one before bedroom
of which there is a lesser need in the
district i mean also regard to the
impact of the other changes
5.8.3 substantiates position taken by
officers and recommending the scheme for
approval
in the planning balance
and as highlighted by an inspector in a
recent appeal decision concerning
affordable homes and the need for that
within the district
the recommendation includes heads up
terms of a section 106 legal agreement
for a commuted summit
and details of that
see the housing officer comments at 7.2
of the report and a ram's payment
thank you jim
thank you mr johnson so members i will
hand the floor over to you
the answer stem and
yeah thank you madam chair um
my only comment is i'm really
disappointed that they have chosen to
not put a two-bedroom bungalow in and
when we know there's a shortage of
bungalows i look at all the developments
especially in burnham on crotch there is
a massive shortage of bungalows in there
obviously most probably not with some
recent appeals at the moment but
i think it would two bedroom bungalow
would really fit nicely on there so you
could have most probably families and
maybe a parent or somebody who chooses
to downsize and could be close to a
family
i know it's not planning matter but i
think it's worth worth saying i think
it's a real shame that yet again
applicants have chosen to come back with
more after the original planning
application that was approved in 2020.
um it is what it is it is where it is
it's just going to create more traffic
on that single 60 mile an hour road on
green lane because they will come up
there
i don't know if there's a
traffic management report or whatever is
going to go in there to make sure you've
got the wheel washing because otherwise
i mean i drove down the southminster
road
when i was looking at the sign the town
sign uh the other day
and it is still even after wheel washing
on that site there is dirt everywhere on
the south mitsu road especially coming
into burnham from the site
and i know developers are trying to do
the wheel washing and then i think
cancer fluka raised it one of them at
one of the previous meetings about wheel
washing again
the town is looking dusty and dirty
because of all the the development going
in there um i think it needs to be um
forgive me if it is a planning condition
mr johnson but you need to make sure
that those big lorries are not coming
via the bottom of green lane in there
and and the biggest the biggest
problem is is there are other
developments happening on green lane and
the the amount of we've got
speeding things going down there because
we've got speeding issue and we're
actually looking for highways to maybe
reduce the 60 to a lesser speed because
it is causing issues
but other than that there's no reason i
know we can't um disappro disagree with
it or not approve it really at the
moment but um
i think it should stay as a two-bedroom
it's a shame it's not thank you guys
thank you madam chairman referring to
page 17
5.5.3 it says there have been no changes
to the scheme in terms of layout and
only minor increase i know mr johnson's
explained all that but when i look at
the existing and proposed
to me plot three it looks to me like the
orientation of the dwelling uh is now
different
so to me that is a change in layout and
it looks closer to the residential
boundary of the next door property i
understand from the report there's no
residential lots of immunity to the
other planned property
however
i just take um
make an inquiry on that because to me
there has been a change in layout mute
point possibly but to me there has but
it doesn't mean to say
i won't agree with the office of
recommendation it's just that
um
going through it and seeing it now on
the screen i believe there is a change
in layout as well specifically regarding
property
or plot three which is now changing
thank you mr johnson would you like no i
don't know i i do acknowledge that i
think i i clearly said that there was a
change in the layout there was you know
without particularly plot three i think
that was what wasn't was an error
probably an oversight in terms of the
officer looking at the scheme in its
totality but yeah but technically there
is clearly a a change in the in the
layout
um and you know its impact otherwise in
terms of the scheme as approved has been
assessed
thank you
thank you council health and cancer
schemes
thank you and i agree with
um councillor stamp about this bungalow
it's a shame that it has to be changed
and
what with what i'm also wanting to know
with them all this energy crisis we have
at the moment is there any chance if we
did pass this
um
that they could have solar panels or
something fitted into the houses
i think that would have needed to have
been uh conditioned when it was
initially agreed would it not mr
jonathan
yeah i mean that that is a difficulty
because um i mean it's a variation it's
under section 73 um
which would mean that variations to
existing schemes can take place without
substantially
altering um the nature of the existing
scheme if we start getting to a point
where we're starting to really change
things substantially changing conditions
and this sort of stuff then we start to
strain into the point now is it actually
the a variation to the original scheme
that's in front of us
now while we're taking the view and it
is set out in the report
that they changed from a
bungalow to astr two-story given the
relatively minor nature of the other
changes is still within the envelope
starting to change the nature of
conditions and add on to that and design
impacts that just may
start
making us think do we have a section 73
application in front of us
maybe a bit of a fine point but um
they're able to put all the extra doors
on and all the extra windows
then it's
that's changed i wouldn't have thought
solar panels are much different
well i mean
i mean it i think the point is we can't
make them yeah i mean it's not just them
putting on solar panels when we're
controlling it through the planet
application we want to consider its
nature it's design etc it's not the same
as if somebody under a you know your
standard house says i want to put solar
panels up and then they cover the whole
roof you know with the sort of solar
panels we don't have any control over
that
oh
i would have thought with the
circumstances at the moment it would be
our job to point it out and push it as
much as we could no i i i appreciate
that i'm just change life does cha you
know as we all know with the war going
on it's changing a lot
yeah change planning law though council
i'm going to go to councillor schemes
now and then councillor fluke
yeah i just want to support uh council
stamp in what she said
uh
it is a source of incredible frustration
when somebody puts in
a
an application it has something in it
that is of appeal such as a bangalore
and then later on they drop it that is
happening more and more
and on bigger and bigger scales and so
you find yourself wondering whether you
can believe the first presentation and
you do find yourself wondering well what
power do we have sure i mean i can see
that in law we wouldn't be able to
change that but why are we well i'm not
going to ask why it's too big a question
to ask but it is a
it is a
you know a source of extreme frustration
among the public and among councillors
that you're that an attractive
proposition is put in and then the very
thing that was attractive is then
removed because they know that they can
do that and so that affects the initial
vote and then you can't do anything
about it in the second vote though i
can't find myself supporting it for that
reason myself
thank you councillor fluke i believe
and then council employees obviously uh
slight disadvantage by the way i know
woodpeckers because
years ago i used to know the person that
lived there and he held some another
place where there were glorious parties
burning week um
gentlemen i've not i've not heard
anything from the the burnham members
that's changed my mind
away from what the officers said in
their in the presentation i think it's a
very good presentation
uh and the fact that we're not happy
with it it's clearly not good enough
grounds to to refuse the application
chairman as we all know
um so joan i think based on that
chairman um i would propose chairman
that we uh approve this offer this
recommendation in line with the question
from councillor helm there council boys
did you wish to um yes uh
i just wish to comment on 5.3 um
affordable housing
uh
in in principle i'm always opposed
um to the thought of commuted sums
rather than providing the affordable
housing in the area that they are being
built
is there any way
that this commuted some
within the 106 agreement when it's drawn
out that this community some couldn't be
ring fenced to development in burnham
extremely good question council boys
thank you mr johnson
uh well i mean
i mean i mean the community some is is
paid for council
um
and
you know the details well not the
details of that but the sort of skeletal
details are sent out by the
by by the housing by the housing officer
it would be for the council to then
proportion it appropriately
so is that a yes technically
yeah but
i i have no control over that element of
the council but you know but but in
theory yeah
um where we do accept uh you know
commuted substances for us then say well
okay a case can be made where it may be
more appropriately allocated if not
particularly on this site and that would
be the only way in which we can then
accept a commuted payment or we would
accept it
rather than who have you been on site
thanks council boys you um yes
um
what mr johnson's
indicated
that it is actually within the hands of
members
um to achieve but i think the internal
system does not allow members
other than when we get a report that
this such and such a community some
should be
uh spent
in ex
position
um so
would it be appropriate
um uh to
uh
to have a report
on the commuted sums that are within the
council and where they have originated
from
um i think it would cancel the boy
i have to defer to burner i think now is
that something well it's not it's not
it's not it's not something for me
yeah burner can you help us out
i'm looking at a picture of
request
trees
uh i can certainly take this back please
to deal with this
and see what we can do
that would be marvelous so if you could
do that and admit that you're going to
do that that would be great berna thank
you very very much
um can we go to a vote now adam chair
could i actually ask mr richard if he
wouldn't mind shutting his window i'm
getting rained on and i can't reach
sorry they've identified purely for
height purposes
rather chilly smell so thank you
thank you very much
counselor channel
thank you we're going back to the point
council of boys has mentioned and asking
about the community some can it be
aligned with burnham
as the 106 is a legal document surely
it's not within the possibilities for
that not to be the case if um they're
entering into 106 and that might be
something that emma holmes could advise
on because bearing in mind when we have
agreed developments are offering up
affordable housing or other such things
we do have a cascading element which we
can apply in terms of let's say the over
55
um big development in burnham where it
was said we wanted assurance as it would
be for local people and it was said to
burn a member and then the cascading so
to me
we've got a development in burnham
that's not providing the affordable
housing but it will do the community
some so an affordable housing element
can be provided it's significant some i
would have thought the legal
106 agreement may be able to
actually um provide
a clause with them that that can be the
case but i seek to take
greater legal advice but could we not
from that committee
formally request within
in our minutes that we seek that to be
the case and if it can't well we'll get
to know about it but i don't think it's
an unreasonable request can you add that
to the previous burner please for us
yes
thank you very much right um cancel us
down so just for clarity are we actually
having that what the accident suggestion
from councillor boyce that it stays
within berlin on crack and we don't get
back yeah we're getting hammered so
counseling has added some
bolstering of of that yes thank you
and it will be minuted good evening
councillor beale councillor floka yeah
thank you chairman can we just be sure
we're not adding a condition
well we haven't added okay no you're not
adding no we're not adding any condition
further information further yeah because
my concerns are arching if you do tie
yourself to burn i mean you don't know
cascade we could lose that but i mean we
all know no i said we all know
as a result of a recent appeal we'll be
getting four and a half million pounds
in uh monies towards affordable housing
uh and before you all get excited that
won't all be going to burnham i'm sure
but we should make sure it stays in the
southeast area yeah no that wasn't a
condition not going
a trustee of an arms house and we're
talk i mean i could build a couple of um
uh
arms bungalows with fort nearly four
hundred thousand pounds
right i am now moving to the vote
members the proposal is that we accept
the officer's recommendation to i think
that's is that a sent
yeah marvellous
oh no it's not
so well that's everybody for apart from
cancer skins who is against
so
moving onwards to item six which is
zero one two four zero var another
variation members
peyton plays nipsel's chase mainland
essex
which you'll find on pages 29-40 i'd be
worried if it wasn't in essex and we're
hearing it
um
now we all as we have mentioned we we
all know
the uh one of the applicants because she
is a counselor a member of this council
so i will now hand over to mr johnson
again
mr chance
okay
thank you thank you chairman
um plan permission sought for the
variation variation of condition two
and the removal of condition eight on
approved planning commission twenty one
zero zero six two eight four
uh which approved the construction of a
single-story self-built live work
dwelling
and that 3.1.1
details of condition to are set up which
is basically the approved drawings
um
now
3.1.2 people specifically at the
proposed amendments
enlargement of the veranda to the front
elevation new window opening to serve
the office new door opening to serve the
utility room
the blocking up of the existing garage
door and create a window and door
opening to serve what would then become
a utility room
uh and condition eight um again under
3.1.2
uh talks about the use of the garage
solely for a vehicle
so just run through the drawings we've
got this
site here
and was obviously familiar with this
case this would have come to committee
beforehand
um
again we've got the site
sort of here
right
okay existing and proposed floor plans
um
now
here's the garage
with the car there
and we can see
under
the proposed drawing it's now become a
utility room
um with a wet room
and some other sort of minor internal
changes there it's got a door
there are
a number of little changes around the
place there's a there's a window here
some of these were mentioned
um
that's the sort of same thing there
there's a door
we go around the building more or less
the same around here everything else
there is more or less the same
um
this is internal the change is here but
this is a veranda
you just see the veranda there again
under the changes the brand is just
going to be increased in depth by one
meter but we can see clearly
um it's within
the context of the building but then the
building is set within its own site so
with no issues there
the proposal a window there again it's
not an issue
um
i think what we're dealing with here is
relatively minor changes which does not
have any impact on the
design of the building in in any way
significant you know had the application
coming like this originally
it probably would have been approved in
in this form
i suppose one thing that probably gives
some consideration was condition eight
and the requirement for
um
the maintenance of a garage within the
property
i mean
i mean had this been a
you know standard house no planning
application
within a garage
somebody can change it into utility room
they wouldn't need planning permission
um
so
clearly no issues with the removal of
condition eight
um
there's ample space around the site for
car parking but in the report it does
set out there's dedicated area that's
also part of the condition of the
original permission that dedicated space
be provided
um
so
the applications recommended for
approval are set up within the report
don't think i need to say any more than
that
thank you members i was going to say
members i propose we support the
recommendation to approve thank you
thank you very much so that's
unanimously agreed
for the minutes thank you
okay this brings us to item seven zero
zero two two four
house pond house scottsdale south
minster
and uh again mr johnson this is found on
pages
41-48
there is no members update for this item
but we do have a
member of the public wishing to speak
who i will call upon at the correct time
so if i can go to you first this chance
in place
right um
if we can have a change of the
presentation please yes just coming
thank you
okay um
pondhouse scots hill southminster
the proposal is definition of the
existing side extension
construction new single-story site
extension bar single and part two repair
extension
construction of the raised terrace and
alterations to the penis freedom
um
obvious recommendations to refuse the
application for the details set out and
i'll go through the drawings and uh
make some comments
you see the site here access
this path here
location plan
really
right so we've got existing under the
post site plans here is the existing
house
and here we can see the new single story
side and two-story rear extension
so just to take the outline here's the
existing house there
over here
[Music]
this is our proposed extension
so
so it's so that's the extension in
context of the existing house which is
obviously the fundamental issue at which
services are
uh bringing members attention to this
recommendation here
and the existing elevations go
in front and the rim
got pitch roofs here there's a
side extension that would be
removed
that's it from the other side
and then looking at the side elevations
we can just dig again
this
down here that's a side elevation there
we can see we've got a little series of
but i kind of separated arrangements of
the booths there but obviously that's
from
front to back
and that's there on the other side
so again just wanted to spend a little
time just to
get the
scale of the existing house
in our lines
so then we then move to the proposed
elevations unfortunately the drawings
are juxtaposed against each other so
very simple to throw in
so
side extension will be replaced with
this um side extension we can see here
again
if i just go forward just to remind you
this is what's existing
and this is what's proposed
i set actually reports over half a week
um
here's the rear elevation now the single
story element does wrap around
so just following this line here
but just this line here this is the flat
roof element
which we'll see when we look at the plan
it's larger contents
runs along here
we've got the two-story extension at the
back
now when we look at the
if we look at the side elevations again
that gives us a context of the scale of
the development
so we can see
the two-story rear extension here
the apex is not too dissimilar from the
ridge of the
existing dwelling
um but we can see
the extent tap which the built form
takes back so when we look at it from
side elevation
at the first floor level we can again
just just appreciate the spirit of
what's been proposed here
again here's a here's a flat roof
element you can see this side elevation
running there
there's that
lantern
light on the top there
again it's quite evident that no impact
on communities the building sort of sits
on its own in its plot
uh but all intents and purposes of
building in the countryside yeah
and despite the fact that there are no
built for immediately a juxtaposed
against it
it's quite visible from all its
all this aspects
let's go into the plan here
now here we do have the existing
building print there the side extension
there
and
we can then see
what's both here
and the report again as i said sets out
it's practically a doubling of yours
fixed existing house is 108
square meters
sorry 200
um
[Music]
right so we can see the
flat roof element there obviously this
is the the pitched
um
sort of
type of the front of it
um this is the two-story element
it's uh in a way sort of knitted into
the existing fabric of the house there
now
these drawings here just to compare
against
a similar scheme um submitted beforehand
which was refused
the current scheme has reduced
the proposal to some extent
of this argument that it's clearly not
enough
propose a building which is considered
to be subservient
and i'll just
go over that in a little bit more detail
in
previous scheme
you can see the site there
view from the road too from the driveway
views of the house from the fields to
the rim
using the house on the side
and closer up
so we can actually see the
general styling character of the
existing building
the
disjointed nature of the proposals
against what's existing building again
that that's that's drawn out of the
report so
and seen that side and rear
so just a
few
comments
um
[Music]
yeah
so
and excuse me for slightly repeating
some elements
uh the proposal would result in a
doubling of the floor area of the
existing
house
in that the width would increase by over
a half as i mentioned of the existing
width a significant expanse of flat roof
is proposed aside
and carplay
which is awkward awkwardly juxtaposed
against original fabric
and the pitch rules of the proposed
two-story
rear extension
the bridge of the proposed two-story
rare extension would match that of the
existing bridge the scale and design
impact can be seen on the proposed
drawing which i pointed out
um
and
and that's compared against the existing
side elevations and appearance and scale
policy of d1 and h4 alterations
extension and additions
speak to the design and scale of
development to ensure it is appropriate
for the location
in this case countryside
and set another site
an existing character of the original
building
it is considered therefore the proposal
fails to comply with policy the
extensions are clearly not subservient
nor are they consistent with the design
of the existing building
um
and all intents and purposes proposes
disproportionate and poorly designed
extensions to the existing house which
also fails to relate to this existing
character
uh
sets up reasons for a refusal along
those lines thank you
thank you so i will now go to the
applicant mr bell so if we could have
the timer on the screen please
uh this is that would be
great i'm not sure if you can help us
out with that
so whenever you're ready okay so hannah
dungay who's dealing with a planning out
there sorry yeah
hannah dungay who's dealing with the
planning app actually asked me to send
those photos last night to help you see
my property and she's forgot to include
the one from the road where you can't
even see my house from the road she's
done the one from within my drive so the
other views from the field they're 33
acres behind is owned by my neighbor and
they've got no objection to us building
beyond that is another hundreds of acres
of farmland and no dwellings the house
at the front is gary and sue they've got
no objections next door is hill view
they've got no objections and i owner
have no objections south minster parish
council have no objections we took
hannah dungate's advice in a planning
meeting online of how to change the roof
line and she advised us to raise the
rear roof pitch to the same as the front
roof pitch and has now backtracked on
what she said and said that now the roof
pitch is existing to the front all of
what was done to that second
pre-planning application from the first
refusal was advice given in a zoom
meeting by hannah dungay
we wrote it back to her she had the
planning application in may it took the
council until december to give her
a decision on it seven months after me
paying them 207 pounds for a
face-to-face meeting 28 days the
original refusal was given january 21
for the original one when we called the
council to speak to it we was rudely
told we're not the applicants down on
the thing we can't speak to anybody
we've been pushed backwards and
backwards by the council and it took for
me to come ask councillors to step in to
actually get decision of refusal for the
pre-planning app because malden district
council have not done their job that i
paid them for and when i sent them in a
subject to contract email calling them
to their rights for not doing what they
should have done they chose to ignore it
and still didn't respond to me and
despite several changes that were put
forward by the council's planning
officer itself they've still refused the
pre-planning
so i don't understand what they want me
to do it's a family home they've
rejected
six dwellings but they've approved a
mansion to be built there and mine has
to be knocked down of 608 square meters
i need to stop you there mr bell thank
you so um
councillor stamp and actually now i need
to go to um initially to the people who
called it in i think and i'm going to do
so alphabetically
so councillor bassinger then council
fluker and then i'm going to oh
thank you i think it's important um
through you madam chair um i was
approached when i was the leader by the
applicant and i actually asked
councillor passenger to call it in
um be when i was um no i wasn't the
leader at the time actually i think i'd
been hoofed out um
that's a technical term um but um
it was me i actually asked for it to be
called in because i i
understood there was a slight issue and
the applicant had liaison with me and
the service that he had received from
the council was was really substandard
and regardless that's maybe not a
planning issue but it really was poor
and the applicant contacted me um and i
did what i could and i contacted council
passenger to call it in rather than
council of fluker because i wasn't sure
what was going to be received
but that's why i that's why i've done it
but no no no it's true
so anyway there you go thank you so
that's the update
don't write on it but that's that's why
i did it
that bit of explanation for uh from that
thank you councillor stamp so council
passenger then councillor fluke
thank you madam chairman well i wasn't
approached by the applicant and indeed i
was approached by a councillor stamp and
request maybe i should encounter
but what i would say looking at this i
can see that this is a stand-alone
property i i can't see any reason
whatsoever to refuse this
it's not overlooked it's miles away from
anywhere and i must admit to me i just
think it would be a great improvement
and i personally would support it
thank you i'm also familiar with the uh
area and i would uh concur with council
messenger councillor floka and then
council thank you chairman i i think
it's time that we had a look at the
calling procedure so that uh all of us
can call in in burnham but anyway um
that's by the way german i um
yes i did call this application in and i
you know i was aware of the background
and i do hope that
burner
will
as soon as possible provide a transcript
of what mr bell said
and send it to the director of customer
services because that's clearly clearly
something's wrong there and i think what
mr bell
says needs to be tested
he has said it in a public meeting and
it doesn't need to be tested now as far
as the planning application is is
concerned um and i'm
very conscious that mr bell's behind me
um if one looks at the the plan of this
site yes it looks like an absolutely
massive extension and and it clearly
by looking at the plan it's not
subservient
but then when you look when you look at
the elevations of the building you can
see how it actually fits in and
if we go
back mr johnson to the scheme that was
refused
there we go now to me
if you look at for example the
elevations top right hand corner it
really doesn't look attractive at all
and the whole scheme doesn't but then
when you go to the scheme that we're
looking at now
without giving it much thought at all
the whole thing just looks so much
better
on the eye
and and whilst we're talking about the
eye german and and uh i'm pleased to
hear that you visit my ward but
regularly
you can't actually
well hardly see this property from the
road i mean i've known this property
forever and it's sort of almost tucked
over the brown the hill so you can't see
it so what's the alternative well in the
words of the of the great henry bass a
breeze block mansion sitting on the top
of that hill looking pretty ghastly you
know we we have some in in in the world
i won't say where but we have some in
the world and they don't look right now
mr johnson said that this this in itself
didn't look right but perhaps we can
have a look at what's there at the
moment
particularly i think the rear elevations
the photographs
photographs yeah
now
i think there's a better one than that
if you go back one is there i mean
looking at this german
and some of this is going i mean i think
what we're actually
you know what what the applicant's
bringing forward here is a great
improvement on this chairman and and i
know that mr johnson has spoken to
policy d1 but i think that what this
application brings forward is enough to
satisfy d1 i mean in my mind it's a much
better than what we've got there it's a
long way away from anything else but i
will briefly talk to subservience and
the members will
remember some of the properties in
orchard road in south minster which are
these large semi-detached houses now
when you have a large semi-detached
house or you you have a house on the
cobbins where you've got lots of similar
houses i agree making an extension
subservient changing the ridgeline is
very very important but when you've got
a one-off building like this you're
almost sort of adding to it chairman and
to suddenly have something very small
next to it or reduce the and this has
got so many different pitches and so
many different roof lines so as far as
subservience
is concerned i don't i don't go along
with that but jeremy before i do make a
proposal can can the officer just
confirm to me bearing in mind that no
neighbours are complained
that the site notice has been properly
affixed to the site
now normally mr johnson someone produces
a photograph but i mean i'm quite happy
to say under normal circumstances it
would be and then we'll accept this
because
nobody's complained about this at all
and it's you know it is
we normally have a photograph somewhere
in the bundle
um
well on on the file
yeah they're normally on the file um
if um
so
if you want me to say
well
perhaps
johnson
i've been contacted by some members of
the public this evening and apparently
if one goes on to uh you uh on to um
what's this thing called where this is
screamed
if one goes onto youtube and you try and
download the papers for this meeting
tonight you actually get the full
council meeting
on the fourth of november
um and the chairman apparently this has
been the same now for quite some time
and and one suspects that whilst people
are enjoying watching the live streaming
they don't download the papers but i do
know that people have been trying to and
they they aren't right well chairman i
i'm sure that mr johnson any moment now
is going to find this
posted on the nearby tree or on a
telegraph pole and turn
subject to that
gentleman i would say based on what i've
just said in as far as the fact that i
think it does satisfy policy d1
and the alterations do
visually appear subservient to what's
going on there's no it doesn't impact on
the immunity because there's no houses
there um gemini i would propose that we
approve this application thank you thank
you and if councillor hale wasn't going
to second that i would have seconded
that from child but i'm also going to
say that it was uh
i know i'm coming to you in a second
then well done michael
i'm terribly sorry i can't hear very
well with your mask on cancer i have a
hearing issue then chairman in
general i'm absolutely sure you do but i
do apologize i couldn't hear you in all
the excitement you might not have seen
mr johnson show you the the notice so
thank you mr johnson that's very that's
thank you
yeah i was going to say that i i agreed
but then i didn't want the applicant to
think i was disrespecting his house by
saying that it was an improvement but
we have a proposal did you wish to i'll
give way to counselor channel thank you
so that's proposed by councillor fluker
seconded by councillor chana
that we um
go against the officers recommendations
and we do approve this application
thank you that that will of course be
subject to the normal conditions
concerning start times finish times uh
not making any mess on the road because
i drive down there occasionally very
regularly counseling
very very importantly as well materials
so
the these would be the standards
yeah so they'll be the standard
conditions mr johnson
thank you members can we agree this five
cents
thank you so that is we have agreed to
support the application and go against
the uh officer's recommendation to
refuse
thank you members that brings us to
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are urgent the only one
i do have is that i know investigations
have gone on
with the i.t department looking to
moving towards burnham in conjunction
with burnham's i.t supplier so
that is moving forward i
i suggest take one on enforcement
justine
i know we're not meeting for some time
but i i think the issue with the
enforcement is getting quite serious
there was there was a question put to
the leader during leaders questions
um and maybe there might be a way
of perhaps having one of these uh
informal meetings they are p and c
mr johnson's benefit they normally took
place during the day
and and the whole idea was really for
for the members to come forward with the
come together with the enforcement
officers to try and
solve this conundrum
even though it will switch but i'm
familiar with here
okay thank you so that
so um members
thank you very much for your
contributions this evening and i'd now
draw the meeting to a close at 8 35.
thank you very much members
and thank you very much berna and ben i
t support thank you all